J'en ai assez !
C'est mon deuxième voyage au japon...
Et je ne sais toujours pas parler...
Ah ouais, c'est plus crédible..
Aujourd'hui on va apprendre le japonais ensemble
Pourquoi ? Parce que j'ai trouvé un jeu qui s'appelleLearn apprendre le japonais pour survivre
Hiragana Battle
J'ai des petites base en japonais par exemple :
Où sont les toilettes...
Je vous prie ?
Comment ça va ?
Bonjour
Bonsoir
Merci beaucoup
Merci beaucoup (quand tu l'as déjà dit)
Voilà on a fait le tour de mon japonais, c'était extrêmement rapide
Nouvelle partie, on y va
Ce jeu est designé pour t'apprendre les bases du japonais
Tu apprendras à lire, et à écrire les caractères de l'alphabet hiragana
tout au long de ton aventure
Allez, c'est parti !
C'est un beau jour...
le ciel est bleu, la neige est blanche tout autour de moi
C'est tout simplement magnifique
Oh, un ami me rejoint
Bonjour monsieur, je peux vous aider ?
Dis moi quelque chose. Est-ce que tu me comprends quand je dis :
kikorodosikarebako
Euh non désolé, je n'ai pas du tout compris
Okay, on va le suivre.
Oh mon Dieu, qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Non mais attend il va m'enculer là, j'ai même pas appris le japonais qu'est-ce que tu veux nan mais, oh!
Si tu ne veux pas comprendre le japonais tu n'arrivera pas à contrer mes sorts.
Putain!
Okay, il a appris des caractères japonais.
Attaque sur le caractère
et ça marche pas.
et il me nique, je me fais niquer par le japonais.
Vas-y, bah tue-moi, qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise.
Ah, d'accord le mec fait trop mal. Okay ça marche.
J'arrive pas à y croire, il est trop fort.
il a dit que pour le battre il faudrait que j'apprenne le japonais.
Allez on l'apprend!
plusieurs semaines sont passer depuis le début des terribles évènements du village
Claire, notre héroïne a passer de nombreuses heures à aider à reconstruire le village
le mystérieux mage japonais a oublier beaucoup de ses guerrier hiragana, dans les terres aux alentours du village
Pah! pire voix off , pire voix off
Okay, je dois prendre un crayon et un post-it!
Vu que je suis un très bon élève bien sûr j'ai toujours un cahier à côté de moi
Alors, le langage japonais a un unique système d'écriture constitué de trois différents types de caractères
Y a les caractères hiragana, katakana et le kanji.
Okay, l'hiragana, c'est l'alphabet basique et en l'apprenant, tu peux presque dire tout ce qui est possible en japonais.
Y a 46 lettres qui constitue... Putain, ça va être long!
Nous on en a.. A B C D E F G... 24
27!
Chaque caractère est utilisé pour représenter un son unique ou une syllabe.
Hey, je note tout mon gars.
Ça fait des années que j'ai pas écrit au critérium sur un cahier à petits carreaux.
Révise tes notes tous les jours et tu connaitras bientôt tout les caractères qui constituent l'hiragana.
Splendide putain! Mais vive ce jeu!
Attends, j'ai rien appris encore.
On va aller individuellement sur chaque caractère et
je vais t'apprendre à l'écrire et à le prononcer.
À la fin de ce chapitre, on aura un petit quiz, donc fais de ton mieux.
Oh, putain!
Les cinq premiers caractères sont connues comme des voyelles : a,i,u,e,o
Hey, notez, hein! Prenez-vous aussi un cahier et un stylo faites pas les mecs
Oh putain!
En fait, va falloir essayer de trouver des repères, tu sais, mnémotechniques là!
Donc ça c'est le «a». En fait, c'est un T auquel t'ajoutes le «o». Oui, je connais cette lettre, là, regardez!
Si on retire le «t», ça je le connais, ça se dit «o».
J'suis sûr que j'ai raison
Alors le caractère suivant c'est i , à voilà c'est le i putain celui-là, je le savais en plus.
Bon, c'est des parenthèses quoi! (rire)
Les parenthèses, c'est le i voilà, repère mnémotechnique, on est bien.
Okay, c'est bon je l'ai!, on est bien pour le moment. Je retiens tout, easy, hein.
et c'est les 2 derniers qui vont faire que je vais tout oublier comme une grosse merde
Alors caractère suivant, ça c'est le U ok on continue. Enfait le E c'est comme le U mais t'ajoute une vagounette en bas
Voilà c'est mon repère mémo technique, si ça vous aides n'hésiter pas à mettre un pouce rouge
Ouai c'est ça c'est vraiment comme le U mais avec une vagounette en plus
Et le dernier!
Aaah!
Ah ! j'avais tord sur le O à j'ai dit que de la merde, t'à l'heure.
«Si on retire le "t" , ça je connais ça se dit "o".»
Putain... Donc ça c'est un mixte entre le premier
et t'as grosse mère
Mec j'ai tout noté, j'ai tout noté actuellement sur ma feuille, normalement je suis bien!
Donc le A c'est quoi? c'est le T avec un O. Le i c'est les paranthèses, le U je sais je j'ai tout oublié
Okay, c'est parti! Ch'uis avec mon gang.
Oh mon Dieu, on a rencontré des guerriers.
J'vais les niquer.
Donc y a un U , un A et y a un ... A, I, U, E, O!
Nickel, donc du coup on vient de se faire kidnapper par des caractères de l'alphabet , très bien!
Donc là tu fais «fight» et je te dis. que ce caractère c'est un A
Allez , Allez baiser le! vas-y c'est bon je l'ai trouvé c'est nul heu allez
Voilà
Je te jure que tu termines ce jeu, je suis persuadé que tu connais l'alphabet japonais mon gars.
Bien joué! Mais Eric et Leon, ils ont été capturés par les  autres guerriers hiragana.
(rire)
J'en peux plus de mes voix!
Y a de la neige ,sa veux dire que je ne peux pas y aller... si, je peux traverser la neige ok c'est bon
Oh putain!
Le A je l'ai bien intégré y a pas de soucis le A il est là.
Allez, vas-y le A dégage!
A, U, I, E, O ok lui c'est un O allez, on va se le faire.
Ok le O est mort, j'ai gagné mon combat entre le A et le O . A et O sont DCD
Allez! suivant on va retrouver nos potos j'avais pris le mauvais chemin
j'avais 1 chance sur 2 bah voilà j'suis un connard!
Oh putain... ENCORE!
un A! putain c que des A à chaques fois c 'est des A j'te jure
A le O, je l'ai two shots allez ça dégage.
C'était vraiment l'équivalent d'un chenipan, mon gars.
Ils sont là, regardez!
Ugh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
Tu t'es fait kidnapper, grosse merde!
Allez, on s'en va d'ici ça dégage!
Est-ce qu'on va apprendre d'autres caractères et à la fin on va devoir en retenir 10?!
Très certainement et au total il y en aura 46!
Il y a des guerriers hiragana plus fort en dehors de la forêt, oh merde!
On doit apprendre un peut plus de choses avant de braver les dangers.
Alors nouvelle leçon, 5 nouveaux caractères HINNNNN!!!
Là ça commence à être dur! Là, ça va être chaud!
C'est:  ka, ki, ku, ke, ko ...
Ohhhh....
J'pense que j'aurais dû continuer de farmer les monstres dans la forêt dans laquel j'étais pendant encore 15 minutes pour vraiment connaître par coeur les caractères mais bon aller vas-y
As-tu remarqué à quel point ces caractères sont similaires par rapport à ceux qu'on a appris juste avant?
Tu prononces exactement de la même manière, tu rajoutes juste un K devant, c'est vrai!
C'est partie pour le premier caractère: ka...
ok ka!
oh putain! là j'vais faire du ka-ka (caca) c'est sûr mdr
Ok on continue!
ki. C'est un D regarder si on regarde bien dans le si on voit un D
le D ça correspond au "ki"
Donc repère mémo technique toc toc toc ? qui est là?
...
Daniel
(rire)
Parce qu'on voit un D donc c'est Daniel qui est là et quand on voit le D on sais que Daniel est là et bah on a envie de poser la question qui est là? Qui c'est quoi? (incompréhension)
Pire technique du monde
"ku" Alors lui quand c'est  une parenthèse c'est u, quand c'est 2 parenthèses c'est "i"
Voilà !ok suivant!
"ke" donc ça c'est une parenthèse avec heu.. un T
Nan en vraie ça va aller, ça va aller
Je pense qu'on va , à moins que le dernier soit compliqué... nan ça va
Je pense que je suis prêt à affronter les plus grands monstres de la forêt
herashaimaset
Ok c'est partie on va mettre tout ça en pratique j'éspère qu'on va casser des culs!
Putain mec je stress, on va se faire aggro va falloir retrouver le caractères ça vas être la merde
Oh, nan, putain je le savais!
Alors qu'est ce caractère c'est un..c'est un... ke
KE !
Là il va prendre tellement cher ce con de "ke" là
Oh il fait mal ! J'ai pas intérêt à m'gourrer
C'est bon j'me suis pas gourrer putain
Ok on l'a eu, c'est bon
Putain si j'm'étais gourrer
Le problème que j'ai actuellement c'est que quand j'apprends, j'apprends dans un certain ordre
Je me repère parce que j'ai mis les syllabes dans un certain ordre
Et c'est en retrouvant la syllabe d'avant que je devine quelle était la syllabe d'après fin bref bref
J'me suis compris c'est l'important
Oh nan.. On dirait que le pont est mort
Ok faut que j'aille de l'autre côté là-bas chercher des bouts de bois
C'est parti pour se faire aggro 10000 fois
Ok celui du bas est un "e" je le sais
C'est parti !
Mais nan c'est pas un "e" c'est un "ke" !
Mais le CON !
Voilà ça passe bien mieux !
Et lui c'est un..
Attends sans regarder j'crois que c'est un "ka", je tricherai pas j'crois que c'est un "ka"
YES !
Je serai le roi du japonaaais !
Je vois un "ka", et je vois un "ko" !
Les rondins de bois sont à moi!
Oh putain !
Toc toc toc, qui est là ?
C'est DANIEL !
Bim !
Qu'est-ce tu vas faire ? Laisse-moi prendre mes rondins de bois bâtard !
Et de 1, et de 2 !
Et de 3 rondins de bois !
Et on a plus qu'à refaire tout le tour et à se faire aggro par 10000 caractères et on est bon !
Donc c'est un "ki" et c'est un "a".. "i".. et c'est un "ku" !
Au revoir le "ki" !
Et bim ! Ça fait mal au cou ça !
Et voilà, le pont est réparé, on peut passer rejoindre.. l'autre côté
Ouh il y a quelque chose de très fort pas loin..
Oh putain c'est quoi ça ?
Oh putain on va se faire aggro par combien de caractères ?
Oh, nan. C'est lui.
C'est Noburo !
Ok c'est parti
BOUM !
Et boum
Et il a fui comme un lâche.
Bien joué la team
Et ben voilà les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo !
Eh... Ouf ou pas ?
C'est hyper malin d'avoir fait un RPG qui t'apprend le japonais
Et en plus tu vas tout donner parce que t'as envie de gagner et de progresser !
C'est notre instinct de try-hardeur c'est plus fort que nous !
J'suis trop content, j'suis sûr que ça va me servir au Japon.
Bon je saurai pas ce que ça veut dire mais au moins je saurai le prononcer, c'est déjà bien !
Sur les cartes des restaurants là...
On se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé.
Si vous voulez apprendre le japonais j'vous conseille vraiment ce jeu.
Il est pas très cher et franchement c'est hyper efficace.
À très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde...